chuckle from your experience or
observation how does one learn humility
and on top of that talk about gaining
more self-confidence
so this here was actually two questions
mm-hmm two questions one of them how do
you learn humility and the other one is
how do you gain more self-confidence of
course I paired these together because
there's a dichotomy in those two right
them if you have a bunch of
self-confidence and you're not being
humble and if you're being too humble
then you don't have self-confidence so a
good analogy of this of course what we
were just talking about jujitsu because
when you start jujitsu and we'll turn
this into a metaphor for life when you
start jujitsu you very quickly learn
number one that you can get beat that
you're not everything that you thought
you were right and at the same time you
start to gain confidence I mean it's it
makes you more confident because you
realize that as you have knowledge it's
the things that other people don't know
and so it's the same thing with life
because if you're in life and you step
out into the arena right you're gonna
realize that you're not you don't know
everything that's something you're gonna
realize and the more that you realize
that you don't know everything the more
it humbles you but also in a in a
reverse way actually makes you more
confident because now you're gaining
knowledge because you are stepping into
the arena so it's like with jiu-jitsu
when you spar and your role you're gonna
get tapped
yes but the more you do it the more
confident you get and the more you
accept the fact that you don't know
everything you don't like the question
before like what are you embarrassed
about
how'd you embarrassed in the sport don't
be embarrassed
go there and get tapped out good you're
learning you know and and that's what
you have to do in life if you want to
gain humility and you want to gain
self-confidence in life you have to
get on the map right you got a step-up
in lead you got to step up and talk you
got to volunteer for the hard job you
got to take risks that's how you're
gonna gain the confidence and the
humility because sometimes you're gonna
get beat sometimes you're gonna win but
you won't make any of that that progress
unless you take the opportunity to step
out on the mat step into the arena step
into the cage step onto the stage step
up onto the leadership pedestal mmm
that's how you make it work because when
you're humble yes that's what humility
comes from you realize that you're not
perfect and you realize that nobody is
mmm so it's like that old thing a
walk-in and picture everyone with their
underwear on or whatever when you
realize that everyone else is human that
increases your confidence mmm do not
look at everyone like they're older
they're masters no they're not they're
just other people and so that's what I
would do if you want to gain confidence
and you want to gain humility both of
them get out there get on the mat get on
the stage or in the game into the
leadership position whatever the case
may be and live mmm don't be embarrassed
and don't be abusive when you do do well
you know that's it say again that's the
thing about jiu-jitsu is the thing about
life you realize you're not gonna be
there's always gonna be someone that's
better than you that's okay just be
humble learn from it and when you know
that there's other people that are gonna
be better than you it's okay you can be
confident what you can do because you
know you're gonna be better than other
people
mm-hmm yeah we were I was talking with
Greg and Tim today about um about
humility so there's like internal
humility and external humility so
external humility isn't really humility
it's the guy who's like super respectful
when he talks to people and how he talks
but on the inside he's like I'm better
than you I know everything and the
opposite is if someone's the opposite
they're on the outside he's like hey
yeah like a Conor McGregor like I'm you
know I'm the greatest I'm gonna beat him
my timing is dope and all this stuff and
how good I am
but on the inside when it comes down
when Owens looking when it's time to
Train he's learning from everyone some
guy a white belt kids up gives him a tip
he considers that tip is this gonna help
me you know so he's his humility allows
him to learn from everybody and you know
he ends up being more successful because
of that humility you know and that's
like the internal humility that's true
statements
you know you know some people they're
like hey I'm I'm not cocky I'm confident
mm-hmm
do you think that there's like a
difference between there is absolutely a
difference yes absolutely difference and
it's a dichotomy because you have to be
confident but not cocky right confidence
like you know confidence saying I know I
could I know I could win this match or
hey I know I can make this happen or hey
I know I can lead this mission or
whatever let's see that's there's
nothing wrong with that yeah cocky is
hey I know I can win this and I don't
even need to train okay I know I can
lead this mission and we don't even need
to prepare that's cocky and that's wrong
right so confident but not cocky it's a
it's a simple dichotomy of leadership
which is actually in the book yeah so
yes there is a difference and or you
know how sometimes some people they
won't do it necessarily in in terms of
being a leader or anything like that
they'll just do it it kind of in life
you know these people it's like yeah cuz
they talk about themself all the time or
something like that right so in those
cases I kind of differentiated it where
a cocky person is gonna talk about
himself and how good he or she or
whatever is unprompted confident is
they're gonna answer honestly about how
they feel about their preparedness or
skill or whatever but it has to be
prompted there are supposed to go out of
their way and be like I am the greatest
you know but if they're if someone's
like hey you know honest question do you
think you're the greatest and they
really think they are the greatest in
their experience or whatever they're
gonna say the honest thing no that's
like a confident cocky I was my daughter
said the other day I was considering
bringing my daughter on the my oldest
daughter on the podcast cuz people ask
about parenting a lot I'm not gonna do
it
but you know I was like what kind of
questions would I ask her and I said
well tell I was just kind of
experimenting and I said tell people
something that they wouldn't expect
about me or something that you recognize
about me and one of the things she said
was she heard me talking to someone
about jiu-jitsu that didn't know me and
they were like oh oh do you train
jiu-jitsu and I said oh yeah I do and
they said are you good and I and I said
like I'm alright you know I've been
training for a while so I'm alright and
she said I was really like I was
surprised at how humble you were you've
been doing jiu-jitsu for twenty years
and you just and you know I said you
know you don't know somebody first of
all that person might be better than me
yeah that's the reality you know I mean
like yeah yeah I'm really good yeah you
know yeah you know what I'm listening to
this and I'm trying to constrain to
think in my experience your reaction to
I need you to two questions in that way
where so I don't think I've ever heard
you and I've known you for ten years I
think maybe eight years or something I
don't think I've ever heard you say yeah
I top that guy out I don't think I've
ever heard you say that yeah the if I
asked you no no I I can't even I can't
really like picture you saying that yeah
I tap alright I tapped him up yeah it's
one of those weird things too because it
it you know one way it means something
in another way it doesn't mean anything
yes I've been training for longer view
you right a mistake you know yeah
exactly that's kind of the point where
it's a grand scheme of things it doesn't
matter you're right
but in this immature way that's in a
part of that if you've been doing
jujitsu for even a little while you'll
have at least this much of it in you
like a kind of thing and I was reading a
thing just Penn online a little fun
thing where it was like unwritten rules
of jujitsu you don't go and talk about
how you tap this guy out today you don't
do that and that's true yeah but the
reason there's an article like that is
because it's a small part of but that in
all of us that wants to say you know hey
you know maybe with your close friends
you'd be like hey did you get him you
know yeah like yeah or you'll come and
tell your wife who doesn't care at all
by the way but it's there in you yeah
but with maturity you're not gonna go
and say hell yeah I tapped in my okay
you know yeah but with you I mean we're
it
especially now we're kind of close I
still don't I've never heard you say
yeah I got him I tapped him out even
when I remember one time I'm not gonna
say who cuz he's a well-known guy and he
came and visited and I will do anything
just beat me I was back when I was a
purple belt and then you rolled with him
I didn't see the whole row I saw you
guys really gonna ask you afterwards I
was like hey so you know like I all I
said was what happened cuz I didn't
remember that's how you'd always ask me
you know like hey what happened you know
like how'd it go kind of thing and then
so I asked you that and you're like it
sound it really felt like you wanted to
say it but it was like almost like you
had this rule almost or something or you
were like weird
you were getting after it that's what
yeah yeah and I just kind of realized
that I don't think you've ever said that
yeah I think that's probably a decent
policy to have yeah I had a guy one time
that passed my guard Annie know was near
some somebody passed my guard and held
it for about a second and a half and
then stood up and and literally ran
around right screaming no this is
victory yeah you told me about that yeah
you know it's dream that was really
strange to you but although I wouldn't
maybe I'm not saying I would never do
that I might do that as a joke you know
but um and I feel where he was coming
you know actually for a while this held
me back because people got so intent on
passing my guard that I had to defend it
as if I was defending attack yeah
I'm not kidding yeah and so now and then
finally like uh probably six months ago
maybe a year ago
I just said you know I'm start letting
people past my guard just so I didn't
play different parts of the game and so
now I just you know I'm not that
concerned about it anymore
mm-hmm people getting all crazy